I wish for film Theory to cross 20
million subscribers
[Music]
all right Matt can't do it what why
listen The Wanted little farty noise
thing so it's against the rules uh fine
I wish for a good morbius movie nope
against rule 101 I wish for another
season of Gravity Falls nope rule
3-15-4-5 fine you left me no choice I'm
just gonna have to prove that there are
no rules that they're all an elaborate
conspiracy to keep stock image fairies
like you in check say psych right now I
will not say psych right now sir the
rules are a lie
and I'm about to prove it
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
and crossferry can't Grant My Wish for
20 million subscribers but you can cast
your magic on that subscribe button you
know one of the classic Nicktoons that I
always thought flew under the radar was
the Fairly Odd Parents being alone with
someone for a long time can get annoying
if it's not the right person are you
leaving me I bet you loved me this show
was unhinged in all the best ways
sorry Dad oh don't worry about it Timmy
my dreams were shattered years ago how
many years ago how old are you and why
not it's a show about a little boy named
Timmy Turner with two fairy godparents
that can grant us every wish sounds
awesome finally every 10 year old's
dream a room full of supermodels can you
guys make cookies super cookies
or I suppose not every wish you see the
fairy godparents do have some
limitations on what wishes they can and
can't Grant all of which are outlined in
a magical legal document known simply as
do rules in fact a show goes to Great
Lengths to explain the rigorous training
that fairy godparents have to endure so
that the rules never get broken and that
makes sense right every magic system has
to have rules three wishes for a genie
no wishing for more wishes no making
people fall in love all the classic
stuff so the world of the Fairly
OddParents shouldn't be that different
right right well you know when I started
asking rhetorical questions like that
it's because the answer probably isn't
as obvious as it seems nope loyal
theorists after watching this show maybe
a bit too intently for a children's
cartoon it's become clear to me that the
rules are actually more like the big fat
lies lies perpetuated by a muscle-bound
guardian preparing the fairy world for
war don't believe me grab your wands
your wings and floaty Crown things it's
time to wish for some answers so first
let's set some context what's exactly in
the rules according to the rules fairy
godparents only Grant wish just to kids
as I just talked about the rules are a
collection of guidelines that determine
what wishes a Fairy Godparent can and
can't Grant to their God kids on the
surface a lot of the rules make perfect
sense fairies can't Grant a wish that
intentionally kills or hurts someone no
wishes for money no wishes that
interfere with love no wishes that help
cheat in competitions no wishes for
anyone except the God child and above
all else a godchild must never ever
reveal the existence of their fairies to
anyone else otherwise they're gonna lose
their fairies their memories and reverse
every wish they've ever had it's a
pretty harsh system but then again it
seems sensible for upholding the
structure of this magical world we're
told in the show that a fairy's primary
purpose is to bring joy and the rules
help prevent any wishes that might
result in a net negative of Joy plus to
help make sure that a god kid doesn't
unintentionally break a rule there are
safeguards in place the wish won't get
granted and instead the fairies wand
dims wilts and then makes a fart sound I
will prove my Whimsy when I change you
in general it seems safe to say that the
rules are fundamental to fairy Society
with the first rules having been drafted
Long Ago by the council four ancient and
Powerful fairies that rule over the
fairy world but the rules also seem to
be a living document with new rules
getting added all the time for instance
you cannot wish for every day to be
Christmas which got added after Timmy
wished for exactly that and things got
messy in a hurry wow they've added a new
rule you really gotta miss a big time to
make that happen but the more you watch
the show the more something feels off
about the rules some of them are just
nonsensical like magic can't be used on
invisible teachers sleeping clowns
French new way filmmakers and anyone who
wears clear glasses as a fashion
statement it's certainly weird for sure
but it's not bad others are just simply
inconvenient like the fact that
breakfast related wishes are denied
after 10 30 a.m but then there are the
rules that are just flat out dangerous
for example fairies must always attempt
to Grant the wishes of their God
children even if they just offhandedly
say I wish it doesn't even matter if
they're conscious or not
on top of that there are these massive
loopholes into rules that Timmy often
demonstrates throughout the show
whatever's in the book is a rule still
Timmy Turner doesn't have to follow any
of the rules this then becomes a huge
problem in one episode with Timmy making
all sorts of rule-breaking wishes for
money to win multiple reality show
competitions and for his Crush to fall
in love with him he later writes that no
fairy god kids have to follow to rules
either thereby causing the rules to
almost self-destruct and destroy the
entire universe every room free wish
destabilizes they look further if the
book explodes so does the universe it's
a pretty horrifying right so the rules
then are clearly responsible for holding
together the fabric of reality and yet
that just flat out isn't true see magic
and wish granting aren't powers that are
exclusive to fairies in this world and
throughout the series we see other
magical creatures completely ignore
basic fundamental principles take for
instance the anti-fairies who are all
about causing bad luck and pain in ways
that break the rules there are also
Genies who basically don't follow any
rules even their limit on three wishes
isn't real and I can't use my last wish
to wish for more witches can I we tell
everyone they can't but really you can
some humans have also gain the ability
to wield magic like the wizard Merlin
and all he uses his powers for is to
help his nephew Arthur win competitions
and become royalty a direct violation of
derul against cheating
is going to be the king of England then
there are the pixies who are just as
magical as the fairies but treat magic
as a business all of their wish granting
is seen as transactional with
bureaucratic rules and red tape that
controls everything and yet just like
any good corrupt businessman the
powerful ones aren't above bending and
breaking their own rules to get ahead
during a mini golf competition that's
subject to important contractual
obligations several Pixies break doe
rules and cheat to help the head pixie
win
and yet despite all of this rule
breaking the universe stays intact but
okay maybe that's just other creatures
breaking the rules maybe fairies operate
by a different formal logic or a
different code of magic maybe their
magic is different and disconnected from
the rest well that's not true either
first of all Timmy and his fairies Break
The Rules all the time to the point
where we could literally be here all day
if I just wanted to list out examples
just for the sake of showing some more
here are a few in ruled out Timmy wishes
his parents couldn't care less about him
violating to rule against interfering
with love in I Dream of Cosmo Cosmo hits
his head and briefly believes that he's
become a weenie that's part witch part
Genie he proceeds then to Grant several
rule-breaking wishes to Timmy's dad
including wishing for money thereby
breaking the rule on counterfeiting to
rule against cheating in competitions
yeah Allen's basically broken every
other episode like in foul bald
Superbike movie Magic just to name a few
that last one actually is my favorite
example of rule breaking because Cosmo
literally rips a page out of his copy of
the rules that forbids him from helping
Timmy thereby implying that fairies can
basically ignore any rule if they so
choose perhaps the most egregious
example of break into rules is mentioned
in hassle in the castle when it's
revealed that Cosmo and Wanda's most
infamous former God kid abused our magic
took out Archduke Ferdinand and plunged
the world into World War one yeah uh
even without wishing directly for the
death of the Archduke World War One
caused 20 million deaths and 21 million
injuries I would say that that one
caused a net negative of Joy nope
something suspicious going on with these
rules these things are supposedly super
important unbreakable potentially world
ending and yet they're broken all the
time therefore they're a lie I've proven
my thesis film Theory becomes film fact
thanks everyone let's wrap it early slap
A Dark Truth and big old red text on a
thumbnail and ship it well not quite
sure at this point we've proven that
dough rules are full of lies and you can
break them pretty much whenever you want
but we're still left with one major
question why if these things aren't real
and they're not being enforced
consistently then why are they here at
all it can't possibly be because it's a
cartoon for children and breaking the
rules would make for easily manufactured
drama no no that's not it see the more I
kept watching and digging into the lore
of the series everything started to
point back to one person the one magical
creature in control of both do rules and
the fairy world writ large Jorgen Von
Strangle self-proclaimed toughest fairy
in the universe I am really tired and
gone strangle and these are my muscles
Jorgen is a major supporting character
in the series The Guardian of the rules
who knows him by heart so he can
properly enforce them he's also in
charge of training fairies at his fairy
Academy boot camp as well as assigning
godparents to new God kids who need joy
in their life basically he's the fairy
general of the fairy Army I will send
you back to the very
thousand years of training but if he's
such a pro of the fairy world why is he
propping up this book of lies well
everything starts to click into place
thanks to two episodes first there's
schools out the musical where the Pixies
attempt to take over the fairy world
remember these guys they're the magical
creatures that are obsessed with
destroying joy and Whimsy and replacing
it with contracts boredom and rules yeah
it's a bit suspicious isn't it in this
episode The Pixies find a sad infant
clown named Flappy Bob and they enact a
37-year anti-fun plan acting as Flappy
Bob's own godparents for decades but
instead of granting him every wish for
clownish fun they mold him into a boring
Harvard Law educated businessman
meanwhile the Pixies tricked Timmy into
wishing that kids were in charge of the
Earth in retaliation against all their
rules and laws but here's a problem with
kids now in charge every Fairy Godparent
is pulled back into fairy world because
the kids no longer need them according
to the rules fairies can only be
assigned to children in need and to
rules also state that if Pixies are the
last magical creatures on Earth they're
granted control over the planet which is
exactly what happens has to be one of
the worst case scenarios for the fairies
who basically only exist to bring joy to
others we're just enjoying the show your
misery is like going to the movies for
us this sequence of events raises a ton
of questions if fairies are kicked off
the Earth if kids are suddenly in charge
why isn't wishing for that something
that's explicitly listed into rules
meanwhile all of this happened only
because Flappy Bob was never granted a
Fairy Godparent clearly he was miserable
during his childhood and yet he got a
pixie for some reason
Sanderson I think this is the beginning
of a beautiful new 37-year plan why
Timmy was assigned Cosmo and Wanda
because he didn't want to do chores I
think an orphaned clown having the
circus pummeled out of him you might be
just a little bit higher on the priority
list most importantly of although how
did Jorgen not see any of this coming
remember Jorgen is the custodian of the
rules he knows them inside and out and
yet he does basically nothing the
hundreds of times that we see him
getting broken throughout the show and
as the trainer and a signer of new
godparents he should have known how
miserable Flappy Bob was during his
childhood and done something about it
Jorgen also isn't surprised when the
Pixies reference that obscure loophole
that gives him control of Earth in the
rules so he clearly knows that it exists
let us go Timmy needs us no he does not
according to the rules fairies can only
be assigned to children in need and as
the guardian of the master copy of the
rules he's one of the only people who
can change them as he pleases so this
should have been something that he
rectified well before it became a
problem so why didn't he why is Jorgen
lying about out to rules hope Jorgen
didn't stop this precisely because he
did see it coming he wanted this to
happen he wanted the fairies pulled back
into the fairy world it's all part of a
larger plan first I thought that maybe
Jorgen wasn't actually a fairy but
instead some sort of undercover pixie on
the inside I mean he loves rules and
enforcing him just like the Pixies
but we learned definitively in the
season 7 episode Cosmo rules that he's
actually Cosmo's cousin thereby proving
that he's a fairy say hello to your
other more deep dark family secretish
cousin Cosmo
everybody
so what then is his deal well it all
comes down to that second episode I
mentioned earlier and then left
unexplained until now for dramatic
effect you see the last piece of the
puzzle that brings everything together
is the season six finale wishology here
we learned that fairies weren't always
the sweet cute cuddly creatures that we
know of today in ancient Fury times a
fairy's main job was to fight not
probably basically fairies were once a
race of super soldiers at war with a
force known as the darkness which was
only defeated when thousands of fairy
Warriors combined their powers to create
a neutralizing light and even then the
ferry Council prophesies that the
darkness would one day return they sent
millions of the strongest fairy Warriors
out into the void of space to create an
early warning system for fairy world
should the darkness ever return
according to the lore of the series
that's exactly why there are stars in
the sky all the stars they're fairies on
the lookout now that's a cool story and
all but just think about its
implications fairy world must have been
devastated by this war with Darkness if
millions of them were sent into space at
the end of the fighting just be a
warning system let's not even thinking
about how many died during combat their
population has clearly dwindled to a
point where the entirety of fairy world
can fit inside of a gumball machine
must be in here and it's not like
fairies reproduce quickly either in
Fairly Odd baby Cosmo and Wanda's child
poof is born and we learned that the
last fairy child born before poof was
Cosmo himself it all started when the
last baby was born in fairy world me and
yet in the past and the Furious we meet
Cosmo and Wanda's very first God child
the caveman credited with inventing the
wheel that means that at minimum another
new Ferry hasn't been born since at
least the Paleolithic Era 40 000 years
ago even the ferry economy seems to be
suffering unable to fill positions in
vital Public Services like law
enforcement isn't there supposed to be a
good cause
we had some cutbacks so Jorgen did what
he thought he needed to do he created a
sham system that would eventually result
in kids losing their fairies and those
fairies then having to return to the
fairy world for centuries he's been
tweaking to rules trying to create a
situation where the god kids of Earth
mess up so badly that the godparents
have no choice but to abandon them
that's why he allowed the Pixies to
exploit the loophole after kids become
the dominant species on Earth he's happy
to pull all those fairies back to fairy
world in the episode we see him being
put to work in real jobs that can help
rebuild their infrastructure he wants
the fairies back to rebuild their
population remember before poof Cosmo
was the last fairy child born and he's
older than the entirety of human
civilization in short when humans came
into being production of new fairies
stopped and without the need to train
godparents there's a perfect excuse to
turn the fairy Academy into an actual
fairy Army boot camp Jorgen knows that
the darkness is going to return he's
been spending his entire life preparing
for it that's why his physique is so
much more like the fairy Warriors of old
and why he immediately takes charge of
the entire fairy world when the Darkness
Returns sending all the other fairies to
to be protected in a gumball machine as
he tries his best to fight back he
begrudgingly teams up with Timmy
summoning loathe he even sacrifices
himself to make sure that Timmy can save
the fairy world that is his primary goal
no matter the cost and here's the thing
his plan seems to work Timmy is able to
dispel the darkness by showing it love
thereby turning it towards kindness and
towards the end of the series we learn
that there's a shortage of fairy
godparents partially because fairies
have begun pursuing careers within fairy
world due to overwhelming demand and
fairies taking on better paying jobs
there is a theory Godparent shortage
that said jorgen's plan didn't work well
enough he still had to suffer through
all those episodes with the dog fairy
what do you want me to say I know a lot
of words cause I just ate a dictionary
but hey if you want some that breaks the
rules of our world you should check out
our sponsor for today's episode air up
the bottle that'll completely change the
way you drink water by hacking your
brain if you've been watching any of the
theorist channels lately you already
know how this works because I talk about
these awesome bottles every chance I get
but if not air up uses scent to trick
your brain into thinking that the
regular old water you're drinking is
packed flavor and it's not using Fairy
Godparent magic for it it's using real
science so how does it work well you may
not realize this but our sense of smell
and taste are connected and what you
smell ultimately influences what you
taste air up uses these little flavor
pods that hook up onto the straw when
you activate the Pod and sip air bubbles
carry the scent flavor through the straw
and into your mouth thereby tricking
your brain it's not like juice or a
flavored powder mixing or anything like
that it is just water with added smell
basically imagine that you wished for
everything that you drank to taste more
delicious all without adding any
calories or chemicals or whatever and
that right there is era when I first
found air up and told the team about it
they were understandably skeptical but
then one of our theorists Mr creative
director for film Theory here Lee bought
one and also started raving about it too
and just like that the dominoes fell and
now basically everyone on the team has
themselves one and we've been getting
them for our IRL friends and family too
my personal favorite is Wildberry but
Lee has been vouching for the orange
vanilla if you want to change the way
you drink water forever click the link
in our description below and get 10 off
your entire air up order using the code
ft10 super simple no complex codes this
time again that is the letters ft and
the number 10 for a 10 discount on your
order
foreign